ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming home Randy Pausch
I'm glad to be here today
hell I'm glad to be anywhere today
president Cohen asked me to come and
give the charge to the graduates I
assure you it's nothing compared to the
charge you have just given me this is an
incredible place I've seen it through so
many lenses I saw it when I was a
graduate student that didn't get
admitted and then somebody invited me
back and said okay we'll change our mind
and I saw it as a place that hired me
back to be on the faculty many years
later and then gave me the chance to do
what anybody wants to do which is follow
their passion follow their heart and do
the things they're excited about and the
great thing about this university unlike
almost other ones I know of is that
nobody gets in your way when you try to
do it and that's just fantastic and to
the degree that a human being can love
an institution I love this place
and I love all of the people and I'm
very grateful to Jerry Cohen and
everyone else for all the kindness that
had been shown me last August I was told
that in all likelihood I had 3 to 6
months left to live I'm on month 9 now
and I'm not going to get down and do any
push-ups
but there will be a short pickup
basketball game later somebody said to
me in light of those numbers wow so
you're really beating the Grim Reaper
and what I said without even thinking
about is we don't beat the reaper by
living longer we beat the reaper by
living well and living fully for the
Reaper will come for all of us the
question is what do we do between the
time were born and the time he shows up
because when he shows up it's too late
to do all the things that you're always
going to kind of get around to so I
think the only advice I can give you on
how to live your life well is first off
remember it's a cliche but I love
cliches it is not the things we do in
life that we regret on our deathbed it
is the things we do not because I assure
you I've done a lot of really stupid
things and none of them bother me all
the mistakes and all the dopey things
and all the times I was embarrassed they
don't matter
what matters is that I can kind of look
back and say pretty much any time I got
a chance to do something cool I tried to
grab for it and that's where my solace
comes from the second thing that I would
add to that and I didn't coordinate on
the subject of this word but I think
it's the right word that comes up is
passion and you will need to find your
passion many of you have already done it
many of you will later many of you may
take til your 30s or 40s but don't give
up on finding it
right because then all you're doing is
waiting for the reboot find your passion
and follow it and if there is anything I
have learned in my life you will not
find that passion in things and you will
not find that passion in money because
the more things and the more money you
have the more you will just look around
and use that as the metric and there
will always be someone with more so your
passion must come from the things that
fuel you from the inside and honors and
awards are nice things but only to the
extent that they regard the real respect
from your peers and to be thought well
of by other people that you think even
more highly of is a tremendous honor
that I've been granted find your passion
and in my experience no matter what you
do at work or what you do in official
settings that passion will be grounded
in people and it will be pounded in the
relationships you have with people and
what they think of you when your time
comes and if you can gain the respect of
those around you and the passion and
true love and I've said this before but
I waited till 39 to get married because
I had to wait that long to find someone
where her happiness was more important
than mine and if nothing else I hope
that all of you can find that kind of
passion and that kind of love in your
life thank
you